understand you've been up to some high
jinks lately Wow
really yeah I just threw that in there
you've been up to you have you got a
little interesting adventure I do I have
I have something to show here a while
ago I was I was watching TV and I saw an
ad at a commercial for Space Camp mm-hmm
which is like a camp that kids go for a
week and they they learn I don't know
you know the skills needed for space
living right yes right I've heard about
this camp kids really liked it right
right it's sorry you know like junior
astronaut stuff and I thought man I'd
really like to go do that mm-hmm
problem is I'm not a child but I thought
well you know I'm better than a child
I'm a television personality I can take
a camera crew go down I don't have to
stay a week I can do all the stuff and
one day ride the rides get the radio arc
the treatment right all I got to do is
do a video of it and well here it is
right I'm hearing the space barracks
with Deborah done who's my space liaison
here at Space Camp she's showing me my
space quarters for my space week hello
Deborah hi Andy it's nice to have you at
Space Camp thank you thank you it's an
honor to be here we're glad to have you
got your quarters ready this is where
I'll be staying that's where you're
staying I'll be in here with other space
campers yes they'll be at least six
other campers that will join you in this
this barracks okay well I want to try
something tell me this I you know I'm
sort of an actor so I like to rehearse
so I imagine this is gonna come up
Johnson Williams dead Oh dad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we've got the level to support
system checks out
h2o dispensed then checks out earth
study what a strange and wonderful
planet this communicators broken those
communicators broken okay we'll be all
right don't worry
oh man oh boy Wow
hey yeah ah boy all I can say fellas
just thank God I didn't want them okay
learning a lot about space oh yeah
oh yeah I see sure this is really I can
I see what I'm Stein was talking about
now relativity a time travel could well
theoretically be possible but I don't
see how it's ever going to really be a
reality in our lifetime we just simply
haven't got the power capabilities I'm
learning a lot it's sort of like being
in the womb if your mother was a biker
here at the hind end of the discovery
shuttle replica I'm sorry dude but it's
restricted access you're gonna have to
watch from Mission Control
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta try the ice cream of the future
that's good
[Music]
help me help me eating ice cream of the
future sick visual check door all right
ah oh you know I felt this before but it
was in college
okay no he didn't
yeah we got him
well that really moved my lunch along
alright thank you
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
anything it's hot in Alabama I learned
that that's one thing you learn right a
lot in Alabama my favorite thing is that
helmet that you wear and meant for
children you should wear that here on
the show Andy what's up
cranial crusher all right very nice job
good to know that NASA is probably gonna
call right now yeah yeah I'm sure
they're right on the line at this moment
we're take a little break folks when we
come but you got to stick around Michael
Rapaport always fine
[Applause]